to be someone who is perceiving or or
positioning himself as as kind of
becoming a global leader in this this in
the in the problem space that he or she
are trying to solve okay and and this
should be the belief if you have 20 more
folks trying to solve it and this is the
21 21st solution to that which is more
of the
same in theory it might be a success but
it's not that exciting right you want to
see some kind of unique approach some
novel solution
which leads to the fact that typically
when we're looking with founding team
you want to see one strong individual
who's coming from let's call it the
problem space familiar with the problem
it's dep it's realistically not just
conceptually and at the same time the
other co-founder should be someone who
idea coming from this solution space IE
the the tech familiarity knowing kind of
what's going to work what's not going to
work how to apply it welcome to
20-minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
Tech thank you H for joining me for 20
minute leaders a not a trivial times but
there's always a great time for some
inspiration and to relive a journey and
one is Al is your so thank you very much
for joining me gladly thank
you wonderful um tell me a little bit
about you know where you grew up what
you know who were you growing up
obviously today you're with you with
capital and and Investments and and you
have quite an quite an amazing career
underneath you but tell me a little bit
about your
upbringing so you know it's funny I grew
up in a place so to begin with when I
was a young student I was not a very
successful one at some point kind of the
teacher asked my mom maybe we should
find kind of an alternative plan for him
because effectively I was behaving well
and everything but I was just not into
studying I was not into writing I was
not into reading I was not into it just
I was bored and at some point I think it
was in the fifth grade or so something
is completely and I don't know why and
how but kind of 180 degrees change and
ever since I mean I've started taking
things so seriously and and kind kind of
that was as a young child very young
child there was kind of a first lesson
that kind
of do never underestimate your ability
to to kind of push yourself forward okay
do not let others kind of pull you
back and you know fast forward 10 15
years and and even more you know later
in my first was the military service and
then career and everything studies and
everything kind
of uh I kind of learned to realize that
uh no is not a bad sign actually it's a
challenge it's an opportunity I'm not
saying that every no evolved to becoming
a yes but effectively when I'm looking
at the key success points along my
career uh the all the common denominator
to most of them or the the great
majority of them was that it began with
a no that's not going to happen we're
not going to succeed it's unlikely to
happen you're doomed to fil whatever and
you know uh apparently some of those
things did succeed so the bottom line is
to trust yourself believe in your way
and and you know be stubborn with
yourself I'm not saying not to listen to
the other person feedback but kind of if
you think that you're doing the right
thing just do it MH and what what things
were you particularly curious about you
know during these times so the the NOS
that you received and the different what
were the elements that you really were
convicted on that you that paths that
you wanted
walk I think that kind of you know in
our profession we're a VC right so we're
looking for good investment that
eventually would yeld good returns right
good Financial returns and with that
kind of concept uh and you know all in
all from different angles colors it is
and shades I've been doing it for
so-called like almost 17 years
now uh it's always the mix of how big
the problem that that those genius folks
want to solve and the quality of the
team you know effective we're an early
stage investor right we're leading early
stage Roy the A and for us this is the
thing right you want to see a team with
a spar with the capabilities with the
hootspa with the belief that they were
able to go through walls acknowledging
what they know as well as what they're
missing which is completely okay no one
should know everything but you should
know that you don't know if you don't
know and what you don't know
uh so far it's been working remarkably
you know so uh we're kind of uh we're
we're finding it hard to let go of that
Paradigm as long as it
works I love it so so tell me a little
bit about Dell Technology's Capital
obviously all of us know know Dell you
and I have gotten to to to to engage a
little bit and for me to get to know a
little bit about your work and I think
it's really it's really amazing and you
have you have work all around the world
but you're particularly focused on
Israel and Europe tell me a little bit
about this group it's connection to D
and what you're particularly
doing so I'd say that it's a pretty
unique team uh in the sense that you
know it's a Founder Le team so Michael
del effectively owns and runs it okay
we're investing we're doing the early
stage invest Tech investment on his
behalf so we're headquartered in in the
Bay Area with also offices in Boston and
Tel
Aviv uh we're leading very early stage
rounds okay where we post investment we
would work very intense closely with the
team do whatever we can to help support
and and for that to succeed and for us
to be fortunate for being part of it
uh and you know uh it's kind of it's a
unique model in the sense that it's
structured like a single LP fund and to
that extent we have more flexibility and
and option to run it the way it should
be unlike the way that it usually is
where you have various constraints Etc
so if we're seeing something interesting
we would invest at least we try to
invest
uh we don't have any pressure to to over
invest I.E invest in cases that we don't
think or we don't want because there
kind of uh fun to to run and and the
need the urge to deploy uh Capital uh so
it's pretty flat model on the other hand
which is also good in my opinion we're
measuring we being measured only by DPI
so effectively dollars in dollars out
okay not on the paper not conceptually
not theoretically not in the future at
any given moment how much dollars
physical dollars we've invested how much
physical dollars with return and kind of
that cleans out the model and it also
adds more I'd say rationality into the
Dynamics with the team okay we're not
pushing them to go with insane
valuations we're not pushing them to
fund raise when they know they they
don't need fund we can invest in as much
as we think and as much as needed kind
of life is very simple for us the good
news the challenging which also good
news to me is that we need to deliver we
need to show physical re Real Results
rather than than you know paperwork and
other uh let's call it synthetic uh
parameters so that kind of keeps our
life very simple and very focused in
what success looks like and what we're
trying to achieve or or help our
Founders achieve and the founders and
the team those are the people who are
building the compan not us let's be
realistic but we're there to do whatever
we can to help and and and support them
and then be there for them and then you
know it's been a great fun it's a lot of
work there's a another always happy
moments because this is real life but
this is the meaning of of you know this
this engagement this
partnership so so know move doubling
down on this on this question of H of of
the structure of the fund that you chose
to to be to be a significant part of
you're mentioning the the dynamic
between the S the simple nature of the
fund but with the responsibility that
comes with it and with the added layer
of
a measurability perhaps or the realism
behind what this represents you know
what how does this impact the types of
companies you're looking at the way that
you're the way that you're looking at
companies in these early stages how does
it shape your your engagement level um
in your in your considerations rather
than perhaps a more traditional multi-
LP fund where you generally have the the
tradition fund structure of raising fund
after fund it effectively has two
aspects or two meanings soall a we need
could do good Investments right and just
to be clear we're not being measured for
our investment we'll being measured for
our returns at the end of the day y so
this is point number one point number
two given the fact that we're leading
early stage rounds the underlying
assumption would be should be that hey
we got to be working together very
tightly and hence there needs to be good
chemistry there need to be kind of what
Mutual to motivation to to engage beyond
the Manu uh and these are kind of the
key the two key aspects aspects that are
being taken into consideration what
we're exploring in
investing makes sense okay so within the
investment world you I guess you're
you're there are areas where where
you're more particularly curious in
especially from from your background in
Microsoft and different different
organizations you know what do you find
yourself more leading into I either from
a a type of leadership of entrepreneur
or type of company type of problem that
they're
solving I think that it should be both
okay sorry for there might not be
satisfying answer but I think that it
has to be a
combination a leader is leader is leader
what does that
mean yeah it means that it needs to be
at the same time someone leading the
Venture and and doing whatever changes
and accommodations needed you know down
down the road and at the same time it
needs to be someone who is perceiv
or or positioning himself as as kind of
becoming a global leader in this in the
in the problem space that he or she are
trying to solve okay and and this should
be the belief if you have 20 more folks
trying to solve it and this is the 21
21st solution to that which is more of
the
same in theory it might be a success but
it's not that exciting right you want to
see some kind of unique approach some
novel solution which leads to the fact
that typically when we're living with
founding team you want to see one strong
individual who's coming from let's call
it the problem space familiar with the
problem it's dep it's realistically not
just conceptually and at the same time
the other co-founder should be someone
was idea coming from this solution space
IE the the tech familarity knowing kind
of what's going to work what's not going
to work how to apply it kind of this mix
uh again given given also given the the
the type of the individual should kind
of bring the company to to to to crack
it you
know and are there particular problems
or particular types of problems that
you're personally interested and
obviously at the end it's it's a very
personal Dynamic you mentioned that yes
you you need to make good Investments
you need to choose good companies and
good leaders But ultimately you need to
also choose the ones that you're going
to work well with and you're going to
support and from from what I hear you're
also very you're also very intentional
in the support that you provide the the
founders and the companies that you back
so what what what what problems do you
think are are ones that you're that you
particularly want to work
on
so I'm I'm glad for the way that you've
kind of defined the question because
effectively to your point we are
looking for teams solving a real problem
or real will pay not something kind of
that's going to be nice to have that's
complimentary no a real painful
problem and this problems would
typically I would map I mean you have
various spaces I would say it goes into
the space of either solving a procedural
issue IE there's currently a process but
it's ineffective it's too much Capital
demanding it takes too long or it's too
complicated to solve it so there these
are interesting approaches and to
resonate with that you have AI ML and
all these uh uh Technologies or or
science behind it that should enable at
least address some of it and I believe
that it's going to be growing portion of
it's going to be addressed and solved by
these Advanced
Technologies uh and you have uh what we
call infrastructural challenges okay in
the devop space in the cyber security
space many areas where there's an
opportunity for a novel Tech approach to
disrupt the way things work or don't
work today to enable that okay so these
are kind of this is a rough mapping of
the issues that that we're trying to
address uh or that we're trying to have
our our entrepreneurs addressing more
precisely uh and you know these would be
you know in in in today's reality you
know
organizations that need to deal with
internal procedures like you know it can
be legal it can be Finance it can be
auditing it can be in the in the R&D
space there are multiple process there
the the larger the companies are the
less efficient they are the larger The
Works workloads uh there are the less
possibilities to address it with with
existing Technologies so we're looking
for someone to go through that at an
able kind of Noel Noel
capabilities uh and same go for the
infrastructure the enablement world
where we see kind of uh unique
Technologies from unique approaches
trying to to mitigate on the lack of
ability lack of
resources uh lack of visibility to
enable uh breakthrough there these are
kind of I'd say these are the type of
things uh it can apply to a IML it can
apply to the modern data stack where
obviously there's a vast realization
that you know in a matter of time unless
you're going to be data driven it would
be very hard for you to survive as a
business mhm and given the competition
and everything so you need to have
unique approaches there how to just
store your data how to manage it and how
to utilize it is much easier said than
done uh and you need you know uh uh
other areas that are also of high
interest would be uh uh you know those
uh what we call Unique breakthroughs uh
in in the way people are doing business
okay and that applies to go to market
approach es to managing your sales
organization your Finance organization
with all the new metrics with all with
all the kind of for many years there's
been kind of acceptance or
willingness uh let's call it to accept
blindness I.E not realizing not really
understanding what's going on within
your organization I think that again
coupled with the macroeconomic
environment that we're living in it's
becoming uh kind of impossible okay
there's as much that you can do without
fully realizing and understanding what's
going on within your organization and I
think that this is one of the major
issues and problems for large medium to
large organizations these days it's hard
to effectively know what's really going
on unless you're going to be utilizing
kind of Advanced Technologies
uh
sounds it sounds like a pretty you know
the way that you're thinking about it is
your you're you've articulated a few
pillars from from unique from unique
perspective into the problems to to to
the founding team the unique perspective
on the problem space from one of the
founders to a probable and and unique
novel solution from from from other
parties or perhaps the same founder
another Pary and founding team you're
looking for novel unique approaches
technologically that are in emerging
spaces that are relevant obviously to
the times that we're in in in these
crazy revolutions and you've outlined a
few of those a few of those spaces ml
data stack Tech stack and um and cyber
security but then that's not enough it
actually needs to also have a
significant impact on on workflows and a
significant ability to integrate into
these workflows and be an impactful
Catalyst within organizations for
adoption and so that there's that sort
of the business aspect of of of the
product and so it sounds like I captured
did I capture those those three elements
that that we've outlined here yeah
absolutely uh do we have one or two more
minutes because I'd like to to to kind
of of put light on a on a different year
relevant topic so without with that in
mind kind of we we discussed mapping
processes and and doing everything let's
take it with your permission to slightly
different world of reality in today's
unfortunate reality here which is kind
of a stress test for all of us
unfortunately we didn't choose it but it
is what it is and we're dealing with it
yeah again and startups are not large
Enterprises so there's still more
ability to map everything and know
what's going on this is kind of
part of the privilege of working with
early relatively early stage companies
obviously today some of our companies
are early stage some of them have
matured and definitely no longer early
growth and the far beyond it when things
happened here uh we kind of took very
immediate action okay call it a manual
action uh we kind of mapped uh we we did
kind of uh I'd say
uh kind of a matrix we try to analyze
what's going to happen uh like a three
think of it like a 3X3 Matrix okay
assuming the things would continue the
way they are for short time call it a
month or so assuming assuming things
would continue the way they are call it
for 6 month or so which is a long period
and assuming things unfortunately
potentially escalate right becoming even
worse and and you know with all the
possible threats all around us and for
each of these scenarios we've def we
we've kind of uh
uh uh tried to Define what are the short
shortterm aspects midterm aspects and
long longterm aspects and for each of
these quadrants kind of we mapped the
key processes okay we've
reprioritized wherever it was needed
we've mapped the key resources within
this with within uh this processes okay
you Capital funds whatever you can think
of okay and kind kind of buil uh a
contingency plan okay for what if okay
what's needed what needs to be prepared
ahead of time uh HR
redundancy proced process continuity
business continuity customers anything
you can imagine right again in line with
the company status what are we willing
to kind of sacrify for the sake of other
things to continue working efficiently
and and normally as much as
possible including unique budget
allocations and all that stuff okay so
kind of that shows you in an ideal world
you would have technology that kind of
maps it and does it for you
but given its upsells we had to do it
manually pretty quick by the way I have
to say it took it didn't take more than
a few days obviously none of us has
expected it it caught us all by surprise
uh nevertheless it was pretty successful
you know it also again it was not intend
but when you're doing such an analysis
it kind of sharpens your understanding
kind of it crystallizes the priorities
and what's really critical kind of it
pushes you into the situation where you
need to make decisions that otherwise
you might have not been taken or not at
this point so actually there's also
something positive about the
process uh and you know there are
derivatives for that right you need to
manage the interface with the customers
what you're saying and what you're not
saying you need to to manage the
interface with your investors mainly
foreign investors right making sure that
they realize that we're on top of thing
everything is being managed we're not
just being driven or or you know pushed
to that event kind of and there was kind
of high
priority uh and obviously in parallel as
a team we a partnership right we had to
fully communicate with our partners kind
of letting them as soon as like Saturday
afternoon hey here's what's going on or
at least that's how we understand it for
now these are the implications here's
what we're going to do everything is
under control and I think this is kind
of critical in this day is not only to
do the right things but also do the if
we're okay and dealing with it people
out there outside uh realize and and
acknowledge it okay not because they
don't want but honestly if you don't if
you're not here it's not really
realistic to expect others to understand
what's going on and all things are being
addressed and and I think that this is a
message that some companies should be
taken into
consideration uh you know the past two
to three years have been unbelievable in
terms of of you know the changes that
that we've all of us had to go through
we had the co we had postco we had
things here locally with our
governmental issues then that there the
war there's going to be a new era the
postwar which unfortunately we're not
there yet but that would pose new
challenges as well so kind of in today's
reality the amount of changes of
flexibility required from from
entrepreneurs founding teams employees
is unbelievable it's
unbelievable uh and I think again
unfortunate situation and circumstances
but I do think that it really
strengthens and put the companies in a
position to plan in a in a smarter way
in a way that not only reacts to to to
prices TY but also to Market changes to
customer preference change to to
everything okay kind of this unique
flexibility cocles muscle I believe
would be a good core competence that
would enable a lot of companies to grow
further and and go beyond themselves
and it sounds like this the the
circumstances that you're articulating
here and and this need to be more
adaptive more resilient to more um more
flexible it it shines light on those
that fulfill perhaps more that fulfill
better the the things that you're
looking for in in these types of in
these types of companies and weeding out
those that are that are really of
excellent and so yeah I really want to
thank you for for joining me this was
wonderful thank really enjoy perspective
I I really really appreciate it thank
you so
much take take care my friend thank
you